y regresamos para las noticias de
economía en france 24 con luisa méndez
bridges buenas noches de nuevo luis y
vamos a hacer el repaso de las noticias
en eeuu o sea la noticia que ha sido la
del día en el presidente joe biden que
rebajó su propuesta de plan de gasto así
es ángela y lo que nos interesa ahora es
ver en dónde se estará aplicando este
posible plan de gastos si logra un
consenso en el congreso pero que incluye
esta propuesta de job aire primero una
inversión sustancial en infancia fondos
para el cuidado infantil y educación ya
que según la propuesta muchos
estadounidenses estarían invirtiendo en
el cuidado de sus hijos gran parte de su
presupuesto asimismo dispone de 555 mil
millones de dólares para invertir en
energía limpia y combatir la
contaminación además el proyecto también
incluye incentivos para expandir la
energía renovable el marco agrega
algunas disposiciones para reforzar la
atención médica incluida la reducción de
las primas de atención y los créditos
fiscales para personas que han sido
excluidas de medicaid por otro lado
algunas disposiciones que quedaron fuera
de este marco una de ellas tiene que ver
con la licencia familiar remunerada a la
que se opuso el senador joe manchin por
considerar que la iniciativa de
reconciliación no es lugar para una
política importante expansiones
significativas a la atención médica
también quedaron fuera el plan para la
matrícula gratuita en los colegios
comunitarios también fue suspendida y el
impuesto al patrimonio que fue anunciado
en los últimos días y vamos a continuar
ahora con noticias de hace desde europa
la presidenta del banco central europeo
informó sobre las expectativas de la
inflación así lo dio conocer christine
lagarde durante un encuentro con los
medios en la sede del banco y después de
una reunión con el pleno de la directiva
en este sentido la institución destaca
que los altos precios continuarán por un
periodo más pero que éstos a partir de
2022 irán moderando se estiman dentro de
la institución que se reduzca a
1,5 por cierto la inflación para el año
2023 américa latina' expectativa en la
argentina por la reunión que sostendrá
el presidente alberto fernández con la
presidenta del monetario internacional-
es la señora cristalina georgieva y es
una espectativa que crece debido a las
fuertes declaraciones de fernández
durante los últimos días en este sentido
la portavoz de la presidencia gabriela
cerrutti calma un poco la atención e
indicó que los encuentros en roma al que
asiste fernández dentro del marco de la
cumbre de países del g20 permitirán
buscar respaldo internacional para
renegociar la deuda con el organismo
escuchemos
argentinas y nos dicen en la conferencia
anterior y si lo vuelvo a repetir ahora
y lo dijo ayer el presidente en su
discurso y lo dice el ministro guzmán
cada vez que habla está buscando el
mejor acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional- un acuerdo que no
implique comprometer de ninguna manera
los intereses de los argentinos y de las
argentinas entretanto en brasil el
presidente y el bolsón oro se refirió en
papeles sociales que debe cumplir cuatro
horas
así es vale recordar que el propio
bolsonaro no ha ocultado su
propuesta de privatizar a esta empresa a
pesar de que en un principio había
negado negado esta situación y una
noticia que se presente en medio de la
del alza que está mostrando el precio
del combustible en ese país
esta situación ha elevado la inflación
en brasil y está afectando a los que
menos recursos tienen en la nación sobre
la privatización de petrobras paulson
ario y su equipo han expresado en el
pasado que sería con la finalidad de
invertir más en el aspecto social por
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo
recientemente
nadie romperá los contratos ni inventara
nada hablé con paulo guedes y puse a
petrobras en el radar para una posible
privatización porque si es una empresa
que funciona como monopolio debe tener
su sesgo social en el buen sentido nadie
quiere el dinero de petrobras queremos
que la empresa no tenga déficit así que
invierte en gas no usted es deficitario
bits infinito convertidas en otros temas
qatar continúa con los preparativos de
cara a la próxima copa del mundo así es
y de acuerdo con la cadena catarí al
yazira se informó que la nación llegó un
acuerdo con un grupo hotelero accor
la administración de los sitios
hospedaje de acuerdo con la publicación
este pacto fue firmado por el comité
supremo de entrega y herencia de qatar
el grupo administrar a unas 60.000
habitaciones distribuidas en
apartamentos y villas para recibir a los
huéspedes de acuerdo con la agencia
reuters qatar estima 1.2 millones de
visitantes durante el próximo mundial y
por favor los indicadores de las
jornadas world street que cerró con
números positivos a lo largo de la
jornada además del estadounidense en
europa donde los números fueron mixtos a
lo largo de las jornadas ya comenzó el
trabajo en japón donde ya las
operaciones comenzaron a la baja en
américa latina' la situación de brasil
sigue complicándose con cierres
negativos en el principal mercado
mientras que merval en argentina logró
recuperar y le deseo una feliz noche a
nuestros televidentes continúen con
nosotros ya volvemos con más
[Música]